a new quinnipiac poll puts joe biden's
approval ratings below those of paul
blart mall cop inflation numbers
continue to shock americans and team
biden is beginning to acknowledge oh
macron isn't that dangerous but they
still want to control you i'm bench
bureau this is the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you probably racked up
some credit card charges over the
holidays because most people do if you
are thinking about the interest rates
that apply to those credit cards if you
don't pay them off you might be getting
a little bit queasy right one now well
this is why you should go check out a
credit card consolidation loan from our
friends over at lightstream lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience that's
exactly what they deliver lightstream's
credit card consolidation loans have
rates as low as 4.98 apr with auto pay
and excellent credit get a loan from
five grand to a hundred thousand dollars
there are no fees you can even get your
money as soon as the day you apply just
for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get that
discount is to go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's
e a l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from 4.98 apr to 19.99 apr and
include 0.50 to autopay discount lowest
rate requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply offers are subject to
change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information that's
shapiro well
joe biden is now officially less popular
than the movie ishtar ishtar has a 37
approval rating on rotten tomatoes
famously one of the worst movies ever
made one of the biggest bombs ever made
and joe biden according to a new
quinnipiac poll is down at 33 there are
forms of bowel cancer that have higher
approval ratings than the current
president of the united states it really
depends on stage like a stage one colon
cancer probably around whereby like
stage four yeah biden's probably more
popular than that but stage one you know
he's probably in incomparable space
according to this new quinnipiac poll
joe biden's approval rating among all
voters is 33
33 plunging toward the 20s this poll is
conducted january 7th through january
10th released on wednesday it found 33
percent of about 1313 adults surveyed
approved of biden's job performance 53
disapproved these numbers are absolutely
abysmal
and by the way it's across the board
right now
the the
general american public thinks biden is
terrible by a huge margin and that's
particularly true of independence
among registered voters by the way he's
still at 35 approval rating
so all voters 33
registered voters 35
among democrats
in november in today's poll only 75
percent of democrats approve of biden
now normally when you have a president
of your own party you're in the 90s if
you're down to like three quarters of
your own party that means that you are
terrible at your job among independents
the numbers are far far worse
according to independence
joe biden is just awful all the way
through
right now the independents are
suggesting that joe biden is a bad
president by a by an extraordinary
extraordinary margin
more than half of political independence
57 said they disapprove of biden's job
performance only 25 percent say they
approve
and of course 95 percent of republicans
say that joe biden is terrible only two
percent approved so i'm not sure who
those two percent are like the entire
staff of the bulwark everybody else is
like no this guy is a garbage president
he is just terrible all the way through
and he's getting destroyed with every
major demographic that by the way
includes hispanics
the numbers with hispanics terrible
right now according to that quinnipiac
poll
white
approve of joe biden 32 percent only 32
percent of white people approve of joe
biden 57 disapprove
among black americans 57 percent of
proof of joe biden 27 disapprove which
is also a terrible number for black
americans for a democratic president
typically that number's up in the 80s
for hispanics according to this cue poll
hispanics only approve of joe biden 28
so lower than white voters hispanic
voters are looking at your biden going
no we are not interested in any part of
this this is a full on disaster for joe
biden by the way just a few months ago
he was up at 49 in that quinnipiac poll
and this quinnipiac poll is reflective
of other polling data that is out there
right now
and joe biden is underwater in every
single major poll there there is no poll
in which joe biden has a positive
approval rating
that's because he's a very very bad
president
i'm looking at the real clear politics
polling average right now
right now
he is on average 11 points underwater
42 to prove 53 disapprove
here are the numbers from a variety of
polls over the course of the last couple
of weeks since the beginning of january
in reuters
he's got a 45 approval rating ibd 44
economist 45 rasmussen 40 politico 44
quinnipiac 35 and that's among
registered voters if you go to all
voters it's lower than that
so this guy is in serious serious
trouble obviously and he should be in
serious trouble because he's bad at this
when seven in 10 americans agree on
anything that is a bad piece of data for
the presidents of the united states and
remember this guy had a 60 approval
rating when he entered office he was not
like trump who started off at 47 and
remained at 47 and then balanced between
like 47 and 35.
joe biden was up at 60 and somehow blew
it all the way down to the low 30s
it's almost impossible to do that you
know how bad you have to be at this job
in order to do that
this means that
by
by pole metrics he is easily one of the
worst presidents in american history and
we're about a year in
which is crazy it also means that joe
biden now has the necessity
to try and and pretend that it's all
because republicans are evil and
terrible and no good and very bad we'll
get to that in just one moment because
that is the new program devil goes down
to georgia joe biden went down to
georgia and uh and castigated all of his
political opponents as worshipers of
slavery which is a hot take when seven
in 10 americans think you suck it's a
hot take that seven in 10 americans are
actually pro-slavery that's uni
apparently including 27 of black people
so that's a unique one we'll get to that
in just one moment first if you've been
thinking about refinancing your mortgage
now would be an excellent time to do so
because at some point in the near future
the federal reserve is going to increase
interest rates this is going to have an
impact on mortgage rates as well timing
the market it can be a dangerous game so
if you're holding off on a mortgage refi
in the hopes that the rates are going to
drop you might want to rethink that
position like right now i mean the
latest forecasts project a few interest
rate hikes this year alone the first
increase could come in the next month
making now a great time to call my
friends over at american financing take
advantage of a free no obligation
mortgage review you will learn about
custom loan options that can save you up
to a thousand bucks a month that's
correct every month from lower rates to
shorter terms even debt consolidation
they can do it all and they never charge
upfront or hidden fees so why not see
what they can do for you if you like
what you hear you can pre-qualify for
free possibly skip two mortgage payments
and you might close in as fast as 10
days just call
866-721-3300 that is
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls
182-334-nmls consumer consumeraccess.org
go check them out right now at
americanfinancing.net
with joe biden flailing around like this
and and with his electoral prospects
looking ever dimmer this means that he
has to activate the the break glass
argument the break last argument for
democrats always and forever is that
republicans are terrible and racist this
is always the break glass argument so
joe biden
yesterday he went down to georgia
looking for a poll to steal he was in a
bind because he was way behind he and
manchin couldn't make a deal so joe
biden goes down to georgia and uh and he
then proceeds to explain that anyone who
disagrees with him on his garbage voting
quote voting rights bill it's not a
voting rights bill it is a voting
rigging bill if anybody opposes this
it's because they're on the side of
george wallace and bull connor and
jefferson davis which is a weird thing
to say if you are joe biden who actually
served in the senate with george wallace
and had some praise for him at the time
here is joe biden i ask every elected
official in america
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide this right
now is the moment to decide whether
you're on the side of jefferson davis
not like 1865 when
three quarters of a million americans
died in battle to decide the question
now 2022 is when you have to decide
whether you're on the side of jefferson
davis and the way that you decide that
is by giving an 80 year old decrepit
white corrupt man the power to rig
voting in the united states that's
that's that's the way that this must be
done
now this has become the democratic go-to
argument
it is astonishing you know one of the
things that people are neglecting about
some of these polling data with regard
to with regard to biden is that
hispanics represent about 19 of the
american population black americans
represent about 13 of the american
population and yet democrats made the
calculation over the past couple of
years that the only voter metric that
matters is black turnout and how the
black vote goes that is absolutely
incorrect hispanic votes are changing
and they are changing very very quickly
to the point that roy teshera who used
to write for new american century and
wrote an entire book at the beginning of
the 2000s talking about how the new
demographic minority majority would end
republican dominance of politics
he's now suggested that that is
completely wrong he's disowned his own
theory
he said just a few weeks ago that if
hispanics start to vote in even somewhat
decent numbers for republicans democrats
have a world of hurt on their hands and
yet democrats have not focused one iota
on hispanic voters
their their only pitch to hispanic
voters seems to be illegal immigration
but it turns out a huge number of
hispanic voters are not all that
interested in illegal immigration and no
matter how many times you say latin x
it's not gonna be a thing
joe biden has nothing to offer hispanic
voters and so they are turning wildly
against him and so he keeps doubling
down on this idea that if you oppose him
it must be because you hate black people
that's not going to win over hispanic
voters or white voters or asian voters
or by the way even a lot of black voters
who are not falling for this trick again
but they just have to keep pushing this
they have to
it's a much more dangerous argument by
the way than even the argument that
trump was making in 2020 an argument i
opposed which is that the 2020 election
was decided by electoral fraud i don't
think the 2020 election was decided by
electoral fraud as i've said many many
times
the 2020 election
was rigged only from the perspective
that the media intervened in the
election in corrupt terrible ways that
the media suppressed information in the
last month of the election cycle that
they reported that they reported lies
over and over about trump and russia for
four long years that they refused to
focus in on anything remotely resembling
joe biden's policy they refused to ask
him difficult questions social media cut
you down at the knees if you asked any
questions about chinese lab leaks in the
middle of the election or if you have
questions about hunter biden's laptop
like all of this stuff was suppressed
so in that sense there was a rigging
that went on and in the sense that there
were certain voter procedures that were
put in place
that loosened voting to an extraordinary
extent and made early voting a thing so
early voting is corrupt just by its
nature because the fact of the matter is
you shouldn't be voting two months in
advance of an election stuff happens
right things change
we should all be voting as close to
election day as possible we changed all
of that because of coven in some cases
that happened without the dent of law
that's what happened in pennsylvania
however does that mean that there were
hundreds of thousands of fraudulent
votes cast and that decided the election
no okay so
that was by that that was trump's
suggestion
is that the election results were no
good
joe biden is now making that argument
about every election result for the rest
of time he is saying that if he does not
get his voting law passed that means
every election for all time
every election is corrupt
you know how insane that argument is and
yet the media don't seem bothered by
that argument and it's not just joe
biden making that argument it's hakeem
jeffries so nancy pelosi is probably on
her way out she's going to lose the
house speakership in november by all
available polls
and uh and then she's probably gonna
retire because she doesn't want to be
minority leader hakeem jeffries is one
of the possible replacements for her he
is a radical congressperson from new
york's eighth district
and here he was yesterday suggesting
that we have to kill the filibuster
and change all voting law in the united
states because of voter suppression this
theory that there is widespread voter
suppression in the united states is
conspiratorial nonsense it is no less
conspiratorial than the argument that
hundreds of thousands of fraudulent
votes were cast in 2020.
the theory of voter suppression is a lie
i i challenge democrats you show me one
person who has prevented from voting who
should have been able to vote in the
last election cycle
one give me a name
like one name that's all i'm asking for
but here's hakeem jeffrey's pushing this
nonsense the voter suppression epidemic
that has been unleashed
by the radical right
is unacceptable unreasonable
unfathomable unconscionable and
unamerican
we must crush it
and we will crush it
that is why
it's essential it's important
it's necessary
with the fierce urgency of now oh the
fierce urgency of now it's all cliches
man the joe manchin freedom to vote act
and the john robert lewis voting rights
advancement act
by any means necessary
including reforming a filibuster rule
that is dripping in racist history
in defense of slavery
and jim crow it's fun that the
filibuster is now racist again so when
joe biden was using it for literally 30
years of his career it was not racist it
was good and when barack obama used it
as a senator it wasn't racist it was
good and when democrats were using it
literally two years ago when they didn't
run the senate then it was very good now
it's bad again also i'm just i will
never i i will never understand why
people feel the necessity to go to the
thesaurus
in order to in order to drive home their
point
it's unconscionable it's unfathomable
it's unethical uncivilized unjust
unreasonable unfair
i mean my god it's unprincipled
unscrupulous ungodly undo unholy
hey or
you could just say one word because we
knew what you meant and it was a lie the
first time it's not just hakeem jeffries
it's chuck schumer so the senate
majority leader very temporary senate
majority leader who by the way cannot
run the senate right now he's running
one campaign in one campaign only and
that is to prevent alexander
ocasio-cortez from primarying him in the
new york senate race
it's not going to stop her if she wants
to primary him she'll primary him and
nothing he does is going to stop her
here is a chuck schumer blasting
george's voting law as voter suppression
even though by the way george's voting
law provides for more early voting than
new york's does
what motivated the insurrectionists is
now motivating these state legislatures
to do dastardly things this idea that
there is no change or that this is in
voter suppression they tried to have one
voting place in the whole county of
milwaukee a million people they're
telling people that in georgia where
there are much longer lines in african
american precincts than in white
precincts that it's a crime to serve
water uh or a sandwich um greatly
restricting or eliminating early voting
saying only one early voting place in
our entire county where you have to
travel 23 miles it goes on and on and on
okay that all of that is not true by the
way no one is preventing anybody from
drinking or eating in the lines of the
voting place and by the way are we such
a fat country that you can't wait in
line for an hour without having a snack
like seriously who are these people who
are starving to death in the lines of
voting in georgia but put that aside
that also happens not to be the law okay
so this is chuck schumer's argument and
it's an absurd silly argument it is also
mirrored by barack obama one of the
things that's amazing here about barack
obama as we'll get to in a second is
that barack obama is truly a person who
believes that his influence is fungible
it is not fungible it is
non-transferable his political capital
is non-transferable it belongs to him
and him only it's more on this in just
one second first you're spending too
much money on gas how do i know well
because everybody right now is spending
too much money on gas unless they are
using get upside get upside is the free
app that i have told you about it is
available from the app store or google
play go get that free get upset app and
my listeners are now making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up you can use promo code
shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per gallon
on your first fill up that's up to 50
cents cash back don't pay full price at
the pump anymore get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank of gas some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to 300 bucks a
month in cash back there is no catch the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime to your
bank account paypal or an egift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is promo code shapiro go check them
out right now get that free get upside
app again it's available at the
app store or google play right this very
moment and use promo code shapiro to get
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up plus another 25 cents per gallon on
that first fill up so
former president barack obama of course
he is attempting to
i would say inject some life into joe
biden's white house and it's not going
to work political capital is not
fungible it is non-transferable if
you're a politician with political
capital you cannot use that to get
unpopular politicians elected it just
does not work that way as a general rule
you might have coattails if you're on
the same ballot
but barack obama endorsing candidates
has never meant a damn thing it does not
mean anything and so when he starts
writing op-eds his first op-ed
apparently since leaving the white house
when when barack obama starts writing
op-eds
about issues like the john lewis voting
rights act or whatever it is that that's
going to mean absolutely nothing and of
course he's telling the same lies and he
says while the american people turned
out to vote at the highest rate in a
century in the last presidential
election members of one of our two
political parties spurred on by the then
sitting president deny the results of
that election and spun conspiracy
theories that drove a violent mob to
attack our capital although initially
rejected by many republicans those
claims continued to be amplified by
conservative media outlets
okay and then he gets to his point
meanwhile state legislators in 49 states
have introduced more than 400 bills
designed to suppress votes
oh really are they designed to suppress
votes all of them does it does it
suppress votes when you say that we
shouldn't just have like pandemic era
restrictions on voting if we shouldn't
have drop boxes on every
on every telephone pole that perhaps
it's a bad idea not to have voter id is
that voter suppression
when you define voter suppression as any
form of voting law it turns out it's all
voter suppression
barack obama says some of these bills
we've seen before legislation that would
discourage voters including racial
minorities low income voters young
people from casting a ballot weird why
why are those people incapable of
casting a ballot
why really i have a question
are none of them capable of getting id
because every single one of them has id
you need id to drive a car you now need
id in order to like show your face in
washington dc i mean muriel bowser put
out a notice yesterday that before you
go out you need to bring your vax card
as well as your id so to go into a
restaurant you need to show your idea in
washington dc but not to vote if
democrats had their way
now barack obama says others aim to
treat certain polling locations
differently creating one set of rules
for voters living in cities and another
set up for people living in more
conservative rural areas
we're also seeing more aggressive
attempts to gerrymander congressional
districts weird because cook political
suggests that the gerrymandering has
been going so poorly for republicans
that actually democrats have added more
seats to congress for themselves than
republicans have in this election cycle
but says barack obama
finally and perhaps most perniciously
we've seen state legislatures try to
assert power over core election
processes including the ability to
certify election results these partisan
attempts at voter nullification are
unlike anything we've ever seen in
modern times
uh so here is the problem with that
republicans have offered in the senate
to vote along with democrats to adjust
the electoral county act
this would prevent
failures of certification in states it
would prevent alternative slates of
electors from being put forward by
states without proper evidence
democrats have rejected this bipartisan
compromise because they just want to
campaign on the idea that republicans
are in widespread fashion suppressing
the vote
so barack obama tries to pretend that we
have to get rid of the filibuster in
order to do this this is his key he says
the filibuster has no basis in the
constitution historically the
parliamentary tactic was used sparingly
most notably by southern senators to
block civil rights legislation and prop
up jim crow in recent years the
filibuster became a routine way for the
senate minority to block important
progress on issues supported by the
majority of voters
but we cannot allow it to be used block
efforts to protect our democracy
so he's saying let's uh let's protect
our democratic institutions by passing a
federalization of all voting procedure
and also
by getting rid of the filibuster
let us destroy the institutions of the
republic in order to save democracy is
the pitch that joe biden is making see
when you're unpopular there are a couple
of ways to fight this one is to become
more popular by pursuing popular
policies the other is to rig the rules
democrats have decided on the latter so
republicans are responding to joe
biden's desperate attempt to swivel away
from his failing presidency by calling
everybody a racist mitch mcconnell the
senate minority leader soon to be
majority leader again he blasted joe
biden in fiery language from the floor
of the senate here was the senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
he compared listen to this a bipartisan
majority of senators
to literal
traitors
how profoundly
profoundly
unprecedented
look i've known
liked
and personally respected joe biden for
many years
i did not recognize
the man
at the podium
yesterday okay so first of all mitch
mcconnell should recognize the man at
the podium yesterday because that guy's
been in the senate saying the same sort
of stupid crap for 30 years i mean this
is a guy who said in 2012 while he was
vice president that mitt romney the
unsweetened oatmeal of politics
mitt romney
was a man so racist that he would put
black people back into chains if he was
elected president of the united states
joe biden is a congenital liar
joe biden is a corrupt politician he has
been his entire career and the the sort
of old boys club that is the senate
where everybody is best friends is
really really silly when it comes to
people like joe biden okay mitt romney
for his part he makes the point that joe
biden is going down the same road that
trump did right if you don't like trump
declaring that elections are are
questionable and you shouldn't be in
favor of joe biden saying that all
elections are questionable unless he
gets his way
he said that the goal of some
republicans
is to quote turn the will of the voters
into a mere suggestion
and so president biden goes down the
same tragic road taken by president
trump
casting doubt on the reliability of
american elections
this is a sad
sad day
i expected more
of president biden
who came into office
with the stated goal
of bringing the country together and
here's the thing about this this is
that's amazing of course joe biden is
now calling on the senate to get rid of
the filibuster joe manchin kirsten
cinema they're not going to do that but
you know who wouldn't have done that
when he was in the senate joe biden i
mean joe biden was literally asked about
this during the 2020 election cycle he
was asked will you kill the filibuster
and he's like i don't think that's a
good idea
we should make no mistake
this nuclear option
is ultimately an example of the
arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party ending the filibuster
is a very dangerous thing to do because
it's been used by progressives the whole
car our whole time to make sure that we
did not get rolled over
um okay and it's not just joe biden
who's been saying this chuck schumer
who's now all in favor of killing the
filibuster for this voting rights
nonsense
he opposed changing the filibuster like
five minutes ago this is chuck schumer
when he had a little bit more hair
in 2005.
we are on the precipice of a crisis a
constitutional crisis
the checks and balances which have been
at the core of this republic
are about to be
evaporated
by the nuclear option
the checks and balances which say that
if you get 51 percent of the vote
you don't get your way a hundred percent
of the time
it is amazing it's almost a temper
tantrum
by those on the hard hard right they
want the judge they want their way every
single time
and they will change the rules break the
rules
misread the constitution
so that they will get their way
chuck schumer should meet chuck schumer
by the way it's always fun to watch some
of this old footage because you see
people that you didn't realize whether
that's preet bharara the the former
district attorney in new york uh who's
sitting next to chuck schumer used to be
as chief legal counsel anyway it's a
side note tom cotton he's senator from
arkansas he went further yesterday he
went on the floor of the senate he just
read quotes by chuck schumer
i will do everything i can to prevent
the nuclear option from being invoked
not for the sake of myself or my party
but for the sake of this great republic
and its traditions
those are powerful words
but they're not mine
every word of my speech
today was originally spoken
by our esteemed colleague
the senior senator from new york
chuck schumer
yeah yeah but
consistency is the hobgoblin of little
minds meanwhile by the way dick durbin i
mean how bad is this dick durbin who's
the senator from illinois dick turbin is
a man so radical that he suggested in
the middle of the iraq war that holding
terroristic gitmo was equivalent to nazi
concentration camps pol pot's
mistreatment of dissenters and the
soviet gulag he had to apologize for
that so dick durbin is no moderate dick
durbin yesterday yeah i think joe biden
went a little far saying that everyone
who opposes him is a confederate
yes there are parallels there perhaps
the president went a little too far in
his rhetoric some of us do but the
fundamental principles and values at
stake are very very similar uh no they
they're not actually it's very similar
at all meanwhile jen saki she dismissed
criticism of joe biden she's like all
these people were fine with trump really
was mitt romney fine with trump i missed
that part here is jon saki being
shinsaki
uh senator rami today basically said
i'll use the exact quote that the speech
yesterday that the president gave was
quote going down the same tragic road
take by president trump and casting the
doubt on the reliability of american
elections does the white house ever
respond to that
with all due respect to to senator
romney i think anyone would note there's
a night and day difference between
fomenting an insurrection based on lies
totally debunked by 80 judges including
trump appointed ones and election
authorities across the country and
making objective true statements which
is what the president made yesterday
about the effects of a coordinated
nationwide effort to undermine the
constitutional right to vote the hell is
she talking about objective true
statements you're right he's just like
jefferson davis it's just like bull
connor
these people are they're insane
now the reason they have to be insane is
because if they re-enter the realm of
sanity they might be held to account for
the fact that joe biden is a terrible
terrible president they have to escape
that they have to escape the fact and
it's inescapable he is a terrible
president which is why seven in 10
american voters now think he stinks
he'll get to that in just one moment
because he does he stinks on covet he
stinks on the economy he's just garbage
all the way around and everyone now
knows it get some more on this in just
one moment first it's a brand new year
and that means you should be pledging to
yourself not to waste your time waiting
in lines when you don't have to this
especially applies over the auto parts
store here's the thing with the number
of car makes and models there are out
there the chances that your local auto
parts store is going to have exactly
what you need really really low they're
going to just say we can order this
online it'll take two weeks and then
we're going to upcharge you or you have
a computer and you can go to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
why would you choose to spend 30 50 100
more for the exact same auto parts at a
chain store or new car dealership for
example a delphi fg 1456 fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey that's 354 bucks in advance it's
217 bucks at rockauto.com rockauto.com
is a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers their catalog
is unique it's remarkably easy to
navigate and you can quickly see all the
parts available for your car and choose
the brands specifications and prices you
prefer amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about xbox so they know that we sent you
alrighty meanwhile
the administration is in a state of
complete chaos with regard to omicron
because again they've boxed themselves
in they do not know how to get out of
this box they've created for themselves
now again they they are in a position
i've never seen an administration step
on its own junk this way it's truly
astonishing just every other step is
either on a rake or their own junk
that's that's all they step on
or a land mine those are the three rakes
own junk land mines that's all this
administration does they just step on
those three things over and over and
over
it's like a bad simpsons cartoon
because here's the thing
they were handed a recovery and they
blew it as we'll get to they were handed
a vaccine and a distribution plan
which allowed everybody to get back to
normal and they absolutely blew it and
they continued to blow it because they
set up an expectation that is just
faulty i've been saying this since march
of 2020. since march of 2020 i've been
saying there's only so much government
can do and democrats have been saying no
no government can do everything
government can control every aspect of
your life and save you all well the
answer of course is that that's not true
it turns out that florida which took
directly opposite policies of of
california for example
florida shielded the elderly and
tranched out the vaccines to the elderly
first and made sure everybody had the
opportunity to get a vaccine and then
let everybody go about their business
florida's death per millions ratio their
death per 100 000 ratio when adjusted
for age because florida's a much older
state than california
florida's
deaths per 100 000 ratio as of january 6
is 228.7
californians is 219.8
okay so they're very very close in terms
of their actual death per 100 000 ratio
and california has been locked down
since march of 2020 right since before i
even left the state
and democrats can't let go of this they
can't let go of this because if we lived
in a normal world where we all followed
the data we would now be done the data
demonstrate omicron is not killing lots
of people it is not
according to the wall street journal the
omicron variants accounted for 98 of
coven 19 cases in the united states last
week based on estimates released by the
us cdc
the variant has fueled a rapid rise in
infections since reaching the us late
last year surpassing surges associated
with earlier versions of the virus and
almost eliminating delta
so far the rate of hospitalization
associated with omicron does not appear
to be as high as with the prior variants
the sure number of omicron cases has led
to the seven day average of new hospital
patients with confirmed or suspected
covenant 19 cases running above at last
at january's record highs however the
period of time that people are actually
in the hospital is much much lower
icu stays remain significantly below the
level of delta
icu patients are way below the level of
delta even though cases are now like
triple quadruple quintuple the delta
cases that we had last year
and yet we're supposed to free we're
supposed to freak out i don't understand
this now reality is beginning to sink in
i think for some members of the
democratic administration they're
beginning to admit things that they
weren't allowed to admit just a few
weeks ago so for example yesterday
rachelle walensky
reality just clocked her in the face she
tweeted this out quote study on severity
of those infected with the omicron
variant compared to delta
53 less risk of symptomatic
hospitalization
74 less risk of icu admission
less risk of death
zero omicron patients required
mechanical ventilation
okay those are the data from kaiser
permanente in southern california which
is the chain my wife used to work for
hey those stats are stunning
91 reduction in risk of mortality from
delta
okay well
delta post-vaccination was already in
had already an infection fatality right
on the level of the flu
if you have a 91 reduction in the risk
of mortality from delta if i could give
you a vaccine that give you a 90
reduction in the risk of mortality from
delta you would consider this a miracle
omicron is that it gives you natural
immunity with a 90 reduction in risk of
mortality according to this study from
kaiser permanente
and and they don't know what to do about
this they they don't know that they
should just declare the pandemic over
and be done
they can't they can't just just say it's
endemic everybody's gonna need omicron
get over it
instead rashov lenski also tweets while
less severe omicron is much more
transmissible we are seeing the
unprecedented impact over 1 million
cases in a day 99 of counties with high
transmission and strained healthcare
systems protect against coven 19 get
vaccinated and boosted wear a mask and
stay home if sick
no okay no
the reason no is because think about
this logically okay if you have the
choice between getting an omicron right
you're vaccinated you're not going to
die from this thing you have the choice
between getting omicron and getting
another variant an unspecified variant
we don't know in the future
wouldn't you rather have omicron
let's say you mask up and you prevent
yourself from getting omicron and
thereby you avoid the natural the
natural immunity associated with getting
coveted in the first place
what have you achieved exactly
it doesn't mean you're going to avoid
covet forever you will get a form of
covid
the only question is you get this form
of code which is super not deadly
according to rochelle wolenski and
kaiser permanente or to get a future
form of cove which could be
significantly more deadly we don't know
theoretically it could reverse itself
but they just can't let go they can't
let go
so they're in this this chaotic
situation in which they want to let go
but they can't and the media are in the
same situation according to the
associated press for two years
coronavirus case counts and
hospitalizations have been widely used
barometers of the pandemics march across
the world
but the omicron wave is making a mess of
the usual stats forcing news
organizations to rethink the way they
report such figures now some of us
pointed out that really we should be
worried about icu's and death i pointed
that out i believe in march or april of
2020 the case counts don't matter what
matters is how many people are getting
super sick and dying
which is why i never cared if a bunch of
20 year olds got the original variant
because 20 year olds were not dying of
this in large numbers
it's just a data disaster said catherine
wu staff writer who covers covet 19 for
the atlantic
the number of case counts soared over
the holidays and expected development
given the emergence of a variant more
transmissible than his predecessors yet
these counts only reflect what is
reported by health authorities they do
not include most people who test
themselves at home or are infected
without even knowing about it holidays
and weekends also lead to lags and
reported cases by the way there's a huge
number of americans who have omicron who
aren't testing for omicron
because they're going to get over and be
done
if you could add all of those numbers up
case counts would likely be
substantially higher for that reason ap
has now told its editors and reporters
to avoid emphasizing case counts in
stories about the disease why weird
could that have to do with the fact that
joe biden is president now and the case
counts are
extraordinarily high
like they didn't mind reporting case
counts in a running ticker on cnn
every day
well trump was president now biden's
president and got really bad case counts
you got to stop reporting the case
counts listen i'm glad they stopped
reporting the case counts because the
case count is a stupid metric i'm just
pointing out it was always a stupid
metric
according to the associated press no
more stories focused solely on a
particular country or state setting a
one-day record for a number of cases
because that claim has become unreliable
throughout the media there's now been
more caution in the use of official case
counts an nbc news story on monday about
the skyrocketing number of coveted cases
relied on a one-week average of case
counts a tuesday story simply referred
to a title wave of cases
the washington post used a 7-day average
of cases compared that number to last
tuesday showing a 56 percent increase
however
a huge number of these stories are now
pointing out that you don't actually use
case rates anymore
even the usefulness of hospitalization
and death rates has been called into
question in recent days according to the
ap in many cases hospitalizations are
incidental people are being admitted for
other reasons and are surprised to find
they test positive for covid said tanya
lewis senior editor for health and
medicine at scientific american
again it's amazing so just when it
becomes inconvenient to count cases and
hospitalizations and deaths
that's precisely when the media changes
this reporting
meanwhile by the way anthony fauci is
now admitting we're all going to get
omicron so the next sentence out of his
mouth should be get over and move on
with your life but he will never he'll
never say that because then he would be
irrelevant again and no one would care
about him
sooner or later as we begin to live with
it what she was referring to is that
virtually everybody is going to wind up
getting exposed and likely get infected
but if you're vaccinated and if you're
boosted the chances of you getting sick
are very very low
okay well i mean that's that's true if
you're if you're vaccinated you will not
die from covet 19. this is this is true
basically from the advents of the
vaccines so why and if you're
unvaccinated that's your choice and we
can all move on with our lives because
we're all passing this to one another
vaccinated or unvaccinated but they just
they can't let go because joe biden's a
bad president and that's the bottom line
we'll get to more on this in just one
second first helix sleep they've got a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why does that matter
what matters to me because my kids wake
me up at all hours of the night which
means that when i get back on the
mattress i need to go to sleep right
away and the best way to make that
happen is to have a mattress that was
made just for me
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else in the first place with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus size mattress
for plus size sleepers
helix even has mattresses with special
cooling technology if you and your
family can never agree on the
temperature of the thermostat that one
definitely applies in the shapiro
household so if you're looking for a
mattress take the quiz order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome you don't
need to take my word for it because
helix is awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by both gq
and wired magazine 10-year warranty try
it out for 100 nights risk-free got
nothing to lose go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you to that customized
mattress it'll give you the best sleep
of your life helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders two free
pillows for our listeners best deal of
the year so far helix sleep.com
ben alrighty we'll get to more of the
news in just one moment first here is
your reminder we are one week away from
my first book club event takes place
next thursday the third thursday of the
month because it is the third thursday
book club 8 p.m eastern 7 pm central
every month i recommend a book that has
earned an important spot in our
civilization we're not just talking
about new books or political books but
classics some of which the left have
chased out of the classroom these are
the key pillars of the foundations of
western society we will be reading them
together not only will the book club
hold you accountable for each new read
you'll also get exclusive access to my
personal notes and analysis and then on
the third thursday of every month i will
be joining at daily wire members online
for an in-depth lecture and discussion
of each book you can ask me questions
directly this month book 1984 by george
orwell so if you want to read that with
me it's not too late to sign up head on
over to third thursdaybookclub.com
receive the materials you will need to
participate in our first members only
discussion january 20th again the first
book of the year 1984 by george orwell
we'll be reading that together head on
over to third thursday book club.com
that's t-h-i-r-d
started on your reading goals today and
then join us thursday january 20th 8 pm
eastern at 7 00 in pm central and we'll
go through 1984 by orwell together
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
joe biden is not just bad on covet he's
also just terrible on the economy right
there's a reason his approval ratings
are 33 according to quinnipiac i cannot
get over that stat that stat is
astonishing inflation has now hit its
hottest rate since 1982
since 1982.
according to the wall street journal u.s
inflation its fastest pace in nearly
four decades last year as pandemic
related supply and demand imbalances
along with stimulus intended to shore up
the economy pushed prices up at a seven
percent annualized rate
the labor department said wednesday the
consumer price index rose seven percent
in december from the same month a year
earlier up from six point eight percent
in november
the so-called core price index which
excludes food and energy climbed 5.5 in
december from a year earlier which was a
bigger increase than november's 4.9
percent rise the highest rate since
1991.
this is because we blew an enormous
amount of money into the system in 2020
and then joe biden decided we need more
of that more of that in 2020 21 and it
was a disaster area this sort of
inflation by the way is brutalizing
workers
according to the wall street journal the
biden powell price increases reduced
real wages by 2.4 in 2021
so you got a pay cut in 2021.
according to the wall street journal
it's important to understand what a
policy and intellectual failure this
inflation represents for keynesians who
are in charge of current economic policy
the biden administration and federal
reserve flooded the economy with money
in 2021 even as the recovery from the
coveted recession was over
fed chairman jerome powell became a
cheerleader for the 1.9 trillion march
spending spree on top of about 4
trillion in coveted relief congress
spent in 2020. the central bank also
declined to withdraw its extraordinary
monetary support despite clear signs of
incipient inflation
when critics began to warn of excess
monetary growth and price increases the
sages at the fed and white house
dismissed it as transitory that failure
is reminiscent of the 70s when
keynesians also ran the economy but had
no explanation for the inflation that
took off or for the stagflation that
later set in as that awful decade rolled
on they blamed corporations they rolled
out whip inflation now buttons and
imposed price controls
only at the end of the decade after
inflation became a political liability
for democrats to jimmy carter appoint
paul volcker to the fed
joe biden remains in denial he said
today's report which shows a meaningful
reduction in headline inflation over
last month with gas prices and food
prices falling demonstrates we are
making progress in slowing the rate of
price increases
but actually core prices without food
and energy increased from the pace of
the previous month
and this entire price is being paid by
people who are in the middle class if
you're rich you can afford this if
you're in the middle class or if you're
in the lower class in terms of earning
you cannot afford it you just cannot
and by the way the supply chain crisis
continues to marinate and percolate p
buddha judge a potential presidential
candidate thanks to the fact that he's
gay he's secretary of transportation
who's presided over the largest supply
chain crisis of my lifetime and went
missing for two months to be on
paternity leave
when no one had suffered any sort of
physical trauma at all
because of course he and his husband
adopted a child
pete budaj he um
he says that the supply chain problems
are going to continue
this guy wants to run for president
what we know is as long as there is a
pandemic it will be creating disruptions
now the good news is we found a lot of
steps that we can take including in the
short term that have made a huge
difference but if we have to bring in so
many goods from overseas
that a shipping issue or a factory
closure thousands of miles away stops us
from getting what we need that's a
problem
oh well
yes it's it's all about what's happening
overseas by the way producer prices
skyrocketed 10 in december that's the
biggest gain ever recorded according to
fox business the producer price index
surged 9.7 in december from the year ago
period
it's just incredible
but all of this contributes to the fact
that the democrats are in serious
serious trouble according to the center
for politics larry sabato at the
university of virginia he is no
republican larry sabato points out that
this is going to be a massive year for
republicans
he says that the republicans could be
picking up
tons and tons of seats
he says in 2020 the republicans won 213
seats just five seats shy of a majority
republicans are starting this cycle with
roughly 35 more seats than they held in
advance of 1994 and 2010 and democrats
are not very overextended at least based
on the 2020 presidential results they
only won seven seats trump carried for
president
however the potential exists for
democrats have for republicans who have
a blockbuster 2022 election according to
sabato
when assessing the gop potential in 2020
in 2022 they think the number they have
in mind is 35. that would give
republicans a 248 house majority house
seat majority eclipsing their 247th seat
victory in 2014 as the largest
republican house majority since the
great depression
they think that this is quite plausible
democrats are in serious trouble and
they can whistle past the graveyard by
suggesting their opponents are racist
it's just not going to work alrighty we
will be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out our newest podcast
morning wire on today's episode they
discuss a new poll that says americans
care more about inflation than kovid
that episode is available right now on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts make sure to tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
krand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our show
morning wire on today's episode biden's
election bill push comes under scrutiny
a new analysis finds the
administration's economic policies added
no jobs while inflation surpasses covet
among americans priorities join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire